today on Matt Walsh Oh some of the
mayor's in major cities that are
currently under lockdown have decided
that they're allowed to break their own
rules because apparently as Orwell wrote
famously some animals are more equal
than others so we'll talk about that
also five headlines including a dad
being arrested in front of his
six-year-old daughter in an empty park
in Colorado because they were playing
t-ball which is against the law now so
that will also be discussed and today we
canceled the media outlets all of them
that have decided to become propaganda
arms for the Chinese government and it's
only getting worse and they're being
more and more blatant about it so the
latest example of this is really
blood-curdling so all of that today
on the way but before we get going with
with them with everything else I want to
tell you about LegalZoom because you
know in these times things are pretty
uncertain and I think it's a perfect
time to start thinking about what your
plan is
now that health and safety is on the top
of your minds on top of everybody's mind
no matter what happens you want to make
sure that your loved ones are protected
in the future
that's why LegalZoom continues to
provide a reliable way for everyone to
set up the right estate plan without
even leaving your home it starts with
finding the answers to your questions
do you need a last will and testament or
a living trust you know what about an
advanced health care directive what's
the power of attorney all these all
these questions I know I have and I can
go to Legal Zoom to answer thankfully
you don't they figure everything out on
your own legal zooms online resources
make it easy to get started and if you
need to speak to an attorney they're
independent attorney network is there to
guide and advise you Legal Zoom isn't a
law firm so you won't have to worry
about expensive billable hours adding up
they're just here to give you
information and so and to guide you in
the right direction to take an important
step for your family today just go to
legalzoom.com to get started on a last
will living trust and more and make sure
that you enter code Walsh at checkout
for special savings that's legalzoom.com
code Walsh Legal Zoom where life meets
legal also before we get into the into
the meat of things I also want to
mention we are a programming note where
we're unveiling a new segment on the
show
that I'm pretty excited about because
you know that um whereas you know I'm a
theocratic fascist dictator and my my
word is gospel everything I say goes
my word is infallible you know and I
must be obeyed always upon penalty of
death so that makes me you know sort of
a trusted adviser and someone whose
advice you can trust and in fact must
trust you you have no choice so the the
new segment we really are gonna have the
ability to actually call in which which
will be pretty exciting we can call in
to show we can and you can solicit my
advice that way but for now if you want
to you can send a video you can send it
to Matt Walsh show at gmail.com if you
have any kind of question any anything
at all any any you need you need
guidance you need you need advice you
have a dispute a dilemma really anything
at all just record a video make it short
don't go babbling forever like I do
maybe just under 30 seconds you can send
it to Matt Walsh show at gmail.com and
then maybe I'll play your video on the
show and and impart my infallible decree
upon your dilemma okay
it will perhaps not surprise you to
learn that our fearless leaders in
government who have shut down nearly
every aspect of our daily lives are not
terribly interested in following their
own orders Mayor Bill DeBlasio just as
one example you may recall that he a
couple weeks ago was working out still
at a gym he was going to a gym to work
out everyone else was told to stay
inside and if you want to work out you
know you could do crunches or push-ups
or something but no he had to go work
out a gym and then this week it turns
out after getting criticism for that
Mayor DeBlasio stopped going to the gym
but he has decided to replace the gym
with instead going to walk in a park
each day and the problem there is that
the park is 11 miles from his house now
why can't he walk around his house
around where he actually lives or
I'm sure there's a park closer to his
house [ __ ] boy or a treadmill I'm sure
he has a treadmill but I know he says
that he was asked about this and he said
that he needs to go to this particular
Park and walk because it helps him be
effective now I'm almost tempted to say
that if this is his version of effective
then we should probably keep doing the
walks because I'd hate to see him
ineffective if this is what he looks
like
effective they can you only imagine can
you imagine how downright catastrophic
his ineffective must be but of course
whether he needs its quote unquote
or not is irrelevant because everybody
else is told not to drive those kinds of
distances for non-essential reasons in
most of the states and cities that are
locked down
you can't drive 11 miles to go to a park
if they find out you're doing that
you're gonna be in trouble and then we
get to the mayor of Chicago she has like
most other mayor's around the country
put her city on lockdown as well of
course closed non-essential businesses
quote unquote non-essential businesses
she's even told her residents how long
they're allowed to spend outside and for
what reasons they're permitted to be
outside so she has said that the you
know be outside is not for five K's so
if you're running 5k five kilometers
it's not for that so she's telling her
residents what the outside is for
outdoors is for a certain purpose
Korda and she'll tell you what that
purpose is this is how long you're
permitted to walk and no longer
now as part of this shutdown obviously
hair salons are closed and residents are
forbidden from getting a professional
haircut and if you are a professional
hairstylist or a barber or something
you're forbidden forbidden from from
operating your business but guess what
mayor Lightfoot did that's right she
went and got her hair cut this weekend
and here she is justifying that decision
listen I'm the public face of this city
I'm on national media and I'm out in the
public eye and you know I'm a I'm a
person who I take my personal hygiene
very seriously as I said I felt like I
needed to have a haircut I'm not able to
do that myself and so I got a haircut
you really got to love that note of
indignation at the end there where she
says you what you want to keep talking
about this you really want you want to
talk about this really this is what you
want to talk about you're worried about
my haircuts so she's tried to get
indignant about meanwhile if you were
caught at a barber shop getting a
haircut in Chicago you could be arrested
and the band the person cutting your
hair could be arrested so that's what
happens if you're if you get your hair
cut but if she gets her hair cut she
doesn't even want to talk about it it's
such a silly thing to even talk about
why are we talking about this yeah I've
only shut down every hair salon in the
in the city forcibly and if any of them
are caught open then I'm gonna send the
cavalry out and there's gonna be arrest
me but no don't ask me about that white
this is this is silly by the way here's
appears of PSA she did a couple weeks
ago telling people all the things that
they don't need to do and there's one
thing in particular that she mentions
that I think is is is of note now listen
to this the data shows that social
distancing works please pay attention
stay home save lives
[Music]
here's what's up if I make this shot you
got to stay home
Debbie kidding your roots done is not
essential your dog doesn't need to see
its friends you can work on your jump
shot inside yeah just a cute little
stylish relatable PSA of the the mayor
telling you all the things you'll be
arrested if you do but it's okay because
you see the thing where she took the
mission with the basketball hoop yeah
that was funny that was cute that was
they they don't makes it okay everything
that she's saying is okay then we would
want to question but she does say
getting your roots done is not essential
so getting your roots done is not
essential but getting your hair cut for
a TV appearance is that doesn't make a
lot of sense but of course the answer is
that her haircut is essential because
she's important yours is not essential
because you're a peon in fact listen to
the reasoning she gave she said I'm
someone who takes hygiene very seriously
think about that justification well I
take hygiene very seriously okay and the
rest of us don't are you saying that all
the rest of the people in Chicago don't
take hygiene seriously now I've been to
Chicago and I could say that some of
them clearly don't but but but still
what is the insinuation here that she
takes hygiene seriously but the unwashed
masses don't so she's saying you guys
can all be dirty and unkempt because
you're the peasants I on the other hand
I'm on television national television
for God's sake what do you want me to do
I would tend to think that actually
appearing on TV as the mayor with uncut
hair would be a great example to set the
fact that she's on TV I would say it's
all the more reason not to get your hair
cut so that you can
show all the all the good people of your
town that you are following your own
rules so we think what's uh what's if
you're in Chicago and you're watching TV
and you see the mayor on TV what is more
important for you to see for you to see
her with a freshly cut hair or for you
to see that she's following her own
rules what is better leadership what's
something as a as a citizen that you
would more like the CI I think probably
you want to see the mayor following her
own rules but here's the really
frustrating thing that the excuses that
are given by these mayor's for what
they're doing the excuses are actually
completely legitimate in a vacuum
I mean without context they're legit de
Blasio says he wants he likes to go to a
park and walk and in something he needs
to do for his physical and psychological
health and it helps him be effective but
nevermind the fact that he's not
effective but but still and I get that
the mayor of Chicago says look I need a
haircut I like to take care of my
appearance I'm in the public eye and I
don't want to I don't want to come off
like a slob and and she also said she
stipulated that the hair stylist was
wearing a mask again in a vacuum that
reasoning is perfectly coherent and
perfectly understandable yeah okay I
understand yeah I get that the problem
though is that the reasoning only
applies to them and nobody else that's
that's the issue because that reason he
makes a lot of sense for them it would
also make a lot of sense for everybody
else the way they're operating in their
personal lives is exactly what the
policy should be so there's the
frustration yes that's exactly it
there's no reason why you can't go 11
miles and walk around a park there's no
reason why the Blasio can't do it
there's no reason why anybody else can't
do it and yeah you know what if you want
to get your hair cut and you're you're
both practicing good hygiene you're
washing your hands the hairstylist
washes her hands and she's wearing a
mask made
you wear masks too it's it's probably
okay what what what are the chances what
are that what are the chances of of the
virus being passed I asked I asked this
exact question before what are the
chances of the virus being passed
between two people let's say a barber
and a guy get his hair cut if both of
them wearing masks both of them wash
their hands and both are not showing
symptoms and I know that you can still
pass the virus when you're not showing
symptoms but that is still something
that lowers the probability right so if
you've got all those things working in
your favor
what's the chance that you're still
gonna pass the virus it's not
non-existent but I would think it's
pretty negligible and the mayor of
Chicago must think that it's negligible
otherwise she would have done it so this
is the point a lot of us were making the
way the way that these people are
operating that's exactly what the rest
of us should be able to do that's the
point just taking reasonable precautions
but otherwise if you're asymptomatic and
if you don't have pre-existing
conditions and if you're not elderly go
about your life while taking those
precautions that may include even
something like wearing a mask that's
what these people are doing why can't we
that would be reasonable and you can
keep the economy going now all this
stuff we hear from the mayor of Chicago
these other mayors but stay home and
save lives and there they're saying that
if you go out and do something like get
a haircut that you're putting people's
lives at risk you may be directly
responsible for killing people well then
she goes he gets a haircut so either
she's okay with killing people either
she really believes that you might kill
someone by getting your hair cut and yet
she did it anyway so she's a sociopath
in which case she's not fit for office
or she doesn't really believe that and
she knows that look if you if you're
taking precautions you're not it's it's
you're not a serial killer because you
leave your house I'm thinking it's
probably the latter
in which case a lot of the things that
she's saying she doesn't really believe
but she's saying in any way to control
people these are
the supposedly from they believe the the
noble lies quote-unquote noble that
they're telling the public for our own
good it's just like the thing with the
mask the CDC and who and even the
Surgeon General told us weeks ago that
masks are ineffective and that was a lie
the only reason they said it was they
thought it wasn't for our own good
because they knew that we're stupid and
if they tell us that masks are effective
we're gonna run out and buy masks and
there's not gonna be any available for
for medical professionals just a
straight-up lie but for our own good how
many other lies are they telling us for
our own good the lie that if you drive
too far and go walk around at a park or
if you're you know if you're going about
your daily life but wearing a mask
you're putting lives at risk or
apparently they don't really believe
that now if you don't think that what
we're seeing here is a is a power trip
and more about control than about safety
and about saving lives and I don't know
what could convince you at this point
that is exceedingly clear yet I still
talk to people all the time hoarse were
skeptical of that you tell them that
these politicians and bureaucrats are on
a power trip and they'll say no no no
it's they're just there dev tried to
help us these are good people they're
saving our lives we should be grateful
to them I can't imagine being that
ignorant and dense and gullible but it's
it's of course that's gonna happen right
of course it's gonna be a power trip
when you give people this kind of
control and power the majority of people
will go insane with it think about the
amount of power these mayors have right
now over every aspect of your life down
to telling you how long you're allowed
to be outside when you exit your home
that's sitting incredible amount of
power and unless you are a person of
great integrity and humility
it's gonna go to your head you're gonna
become a petty tyrant like these people
have and we know that mayor light-footed
mayor de Blasio and a lot of the other
ones they certainly are not people of
great integrity humility that much is
clear
all right let's move on to headlines at
the White House press briefing yesterday
dr. Burks made an interesting admission
I thought this was really worth paying
attention to listen to this so I think
in this country we've taken a very
liberal approach to mortality and I
think the reporting here has been pretty
straightforward over the last five to
six weeks prior to that when there
wasn't testing in January and February
that's a very different situation and
unknown there are other countries that
if you had a pre-existing condition and
let's say the virus called you to go to
the ICU and then have a heart or kidney
problem some countries are recording
that as a heart issue or a kidney issue
and not a kovin 19 death right now we're
still recording it and we all I mean the
great thing about having forms that come
in and a form that has the ability to
mark it as covert 19 infection the
intent is right now that those if
someone dies with Kovan 19 we are
counting that as a copan 19 death a
liberal approach to mortality okay so
she says and I want to get the exact
quote right she says if someone dies
with Kovan 19 we are counting that as a
kovat 19 death the problem with that
should be obvious that's their exact
quote that's what she said the problem
is that just because someone has a virus
and then dies doesn't mean that they
died of the virus and that's just like
with anything else if somebody dies and
it turns out they had pancreatic cancer
doesn't necessarily mean they died of
the cancer they could have died of
something else it could have died of the
cancer but doesn't mean they did
automatically and considering that so
many of the Cova 19 deaths the vast
majority of fact are people
preexisting conditions you have to
wonder how many of them died from the
virus as opposed to merely with the
virus and what she's telling us plain as
day is that they're not making a
distinction in this country anyway we're
not making distinction between dying
with the virus and dying from the virus
even though there is a very very clear
and important distinction number two a
father in Colorado was playing t-ball
with his daughter in a park and wound up
getting handcuffed and arrested for it
supposedly he was violating social
distancing despite being with his own
family in apparently an empty Park
playing t-ball they were arrested so
this is where we aren't him a man being
cuffed in front of his six-year-old
daughter putting a squad car here's the
report done by Fox 31 in Denver watch
Matt moody assist his family just wanted
some fresh air so they went to an open
space to play some t-ball never guessing
would land him in the back of a police
cruiser now he was a public apology
brytny police are apparently arresting a
dad for throwing a ball to his daughter
it was a former city council member who
could not believe what he was recording
in a park of about 30-40 acres but
apparently that is not allowed
information we're going to put you in
front of your six-year-old daughter
Matt Mooney is the 33 year old dad who
assured his daughter they were doing
nothing wrong when police approached and
told them they were violating the
state's social distancing guidelines
she's like daddy I don't want you to get
arrested and you know at this point I'm
thinking there's no way they're gonna
arrest me
no there's no way this is insane and you
know so I'm telling her I'm like don't
worry daddy's not gonna get arrested you
know I've done nothing wrong you know
don't worry about it and then they
arrest the sign at Donelson park says
closed but in smaller print says in
groups of no more than four persons
parks remain open for walking hiking
biking running and similar activities
Matt was just there with his wife and
six-year-old he says it was the officers
who are violating social distancing
guidelines during this little contact
you know none of the officers had masks
on none of them
gloves on you know and they're in my
face handcuffing me there they're
touching me now first of all this isn't
really the most important point here but
what the hell kind of camera would see
for court hang on what how do you even
get footage like that these days and
what was he jumping around on a
trampoline while he was recording it it
was just the grania stand jumpiest
footage of something i've seen in a long
time it looked like battlefield footage
from from like World War one or
something dudes out there with a with a
video camera from 1917 I guess he got it
from the same store that all the people
who have spotted Bigfoot gets their get
their cameras but anyway that's not what
the excuse you'll hear is that the guy
was arrested not because he was playing
t-ball on a park but because he which
which it even said there in the in the
package that that's you're allowed to do
that even by the draconian law is that
they put in place there in Colorado
you're still allowed to go to a park as
long as you don't have more than four
people and you're doing some approved
activity which it would seem that you
know a guy going with his daughter and I
think is the mom was there playing
t-ball would be a fine activity so he
wasn't actually arrested for that he was
arrested because you wouldn't show his
ID a cop came up to him and asked for
his ID and he wouldn't provide his ID
but why should he have to give his ID
when he's in a park playing with his
daughter why would a cop even ask for it
what does your ID have to do with
anything
do you need a license to play in a park
with your daughter what are you asking
for the license in the first place and
in America it's supposed to be that
accompanies to have a reason to ask you
for something like that maybe what is it
basically it's now a cop is coming up
and demanding to see your papers
that's essentially what this is number
three here's the headline for the New
York Times that says environmentalists
are using these strange times to make a
point
pollution is not something that can't
that can't be reversed
we've just reversed it and I bring this
to your attention again only as further
support for the point that I was making
a couple weeks ago and that many people
have made
that this what we're seeing now is
setting a precedent that the left is
absolutely going to use and there they
are advertising the fact that they're
going to use it and so here they're
saying look we can we can stop pollution
of course all you have to do to cut back
on pollution is just to grind the global
economy to a halt and send millions of
people plunging into destitution but it
can be done apparently so look out for
the next Democratic administration
number four the White House is now
saying that it would like to start
reopening the economy in four to eight
weeks is what they're saying now it's of
course there's a lot of vagueness as
usual and it's indicated that it could
be earlier than that it could be later
than that who knows but they're shooting
for four to eight weeks of course the
problem is four to eight weeks if you
try to reopen the economy in four to
eight weeks there's not going to be an
economy to reopen that is much too far
in the future that is way too long
it's already been too long and this
vagueness again this vagueness is the
ambiguity is a big part of the problem
it's you you just you can't do this you
can't put people's lives on hold
indefinitely and not tell them when it's
gonna be over businesses need to plan
ahead if they have any chance of
surviving families need to be able to
plan ahead and budget and they need to
know if you've got a family without an
income right now they need to know how
long am I gonna be without an income I
might have some savings but I gotta know
how I'm rationing this thing out number
five legendary songwriter John Prine
died at the age of 73 from we're told
according to reports complications
related to corona virus you know this
one
this one I'm pretty broken up about
personally John Prine has been one of my
favorite artists just a brilliant
songwriter is to say he had this
incredible ability ability to tell
stories through song but what was unique
about
John Prine and there's a startling
number of people I discovered last night
and I was talking about this online
startling number of people who've never
heard of John Prine I don't know how you
but if that's the case go look him up he
tells he's a great storyteller through
SOG but what was unique is that he would
tell other people's stories much of the
time
music today often rears much more
towards the self referential where the
artist is constantly talking about
himself which there's not anything wrong
with that necessarily but I think most
of John Prime's greatest songs were
about other people so he was I suppose
America's most empathetic songwriter you
might say angel for Montgomery probably
the most well-known song beautiful song
is a song about an aging woman in a
loveless marriage he wrote that you know
despite not being a woman himself and he
wrote that as a young man hello in there
is a song about the elderly another
beautiful song and about the loneliness
of aging but he wrote that when he was
in I think his 20s Sam a song called Sam
stone another great song John Prine song
a song about a drug-addicted veteran so
just songs with depth and meaning very
lyrical and I would put John Prine
probably above Bob Dylan as a personal
preference certainly I would say John
Prine was writing great songs for longer
than Bob Dylan has again in my opinion
number 6 a bonus story just to lighten
things up a little bit some some just to
give us something to point laughs at
because it's been pretty heavy up until
now so some Democrats in Congress have
been trying to set a good example
walking around in masks okay good for
them the only problem is that well look
at living these pictures here we've got
Chuck Schumer and Sheila jackson-lee
wearing masks what's the problem here
with the way they're way that there
seems to be a conceptual problem they
seem to be having an issue with the very
concept of the mask covering why is Siri
talking to me hold on what do you want
sir
what do you want why are you talking to
me are we all gonna die Seri Seri Seri
okay that was creepy they're listening
she's listening she's listening to every
word I say
anyway we're worried okay so yeah they
don't know how to wear masks they're
they leaving leaving the nose uncovered
but the mouth heads it's kind of like a
football player wearing a face mask but
no helmet kind of defeats the purpose
let's go to your daily cancelation this
will be a quick one people people's
daily is a propaganda outfit for the
Chinese government and it poses as a
news outlet of course as as all
propaganda outfits do yesterday it
posted a video of a video that I think
this video deserves to be mentioned in
the dictionary under tone-deaf because
look at this screenshot they deleted it
apparently I'm just discovering so they
took it down but here's a screenshot it
says look at it says have a taste of
Wuhan let these mouth-watering
specialties in Wuhan satisfy your
stomach a taste of Wuhan mouth-watering
specials yes yes we've had a taste of
Wuhan alright we've had quite enough of
Wuhan I think the entire world has what
do you think though you see that dish
there
what is that dish in the picture because
it's got feel very it's kind of sort of
dark black substance I'm thinking it
looks maybe like a ground bat over pasta
with scallions which is a pretty good
dish by the way definitely a staple in
my house kind of a comfort food I grew
up with it I do prefer usually my bat to
be seared in a cast-iron skillet and
then just lightly baked so what you're
going for is that crispy crust of the
bat and then inside you want a nice
medium rare cook that's how I prefer it
really delicious
you know if I'm if I'm gonna cancel
anyone for Chinese propaganda actually
it shouldn't be a Chinese propaganda
outlet because that's their job right is
to just do Chinese propaganda and so you
can hardly blame before but I think our
media our media doing propaganda for the
Chinese government that's a much bigger
problem so for example there are many
examples of this here's the latest one
of the most egregious ABC news this
morning posted a video from China of a
light show that the government put on to
celebrate that they're opening Wuhan
again and here's the video this is a
video that ABC News posted on their
Twitter account watch
[Music]
okay so that is literal Chinese state
propaganda that ABC News is passing
along they're not reporting on it
they're not offering commentary on it
they're just passing it along like a
like the Chinese propaganda outlets in
China do the Chinese government comes up
with the propaganda piece the video
package and they just aside they hand it
out and and now even our media says okay
well we'll go ahead and amplify that
message for you absolutely despicable
let's move on to emails and you can
email the show you got to become a daily
while remember if your daily while
remember you have access to the mailbag
and you can send your your emails and as
always I do enjoy emails telling me why
I'm wrong about things so that we can
argue with each other which is my
favorite pastime so I've got a why I'm
wrong email but first a couple others I
wanted to read briefly this is from Liz
it says I just wanted to say I too
suffer from the fear of elevators
shooting out of the top of the building
I was I divulged that irrational fear of
mine yesterday and then immediately
regretted saying it out loud
although I got a few emails from people
saying that they this is apparently a
more common fear than I thought Liz says
I was recently well not too recently in
a hospital and needed to go to the top
floor unbeknownst to me the attached
parking garage was not as tall as the
hospital itself I get the elevator one
with a glass side that's exposed to said
parking garage as the elevator climbed
to began going above the parking garage
and I lost my mind my brain ceased
functioning and as I saw the parking
garage get farther below me I thought
for sure my fear was coming to fruition
rest assured the elevator stopped safely
at the top of the hospital let me out
and I haven't stepped foot on one sense
I'm just glad to know I'm not alone Liz
so it's me Liz I think was to other
people that emailed and said they have
us the same fear not of the I never
worry about an elevator crashing that
would be way too reasonable to worry
about that my my worry is that something
malfunctioned it just blasts out the top
of the building this is from Chad it
says thank you for bringing up the
article about the
there the virus reactivating and how the
science does not support this I am a
biochemist in Michigan that
predominantly studies pediatric cancer
however with the current situation the
local hospital system has elicited
support from the University I work for
to do literature reviews for scientific
papers involving kovat 19 so as to help
emphasize what literature should be
reviewed by local clinicians as they
prepared to care for infected patients I
was eager to be involved in the process
in a - it's in a small way contribute in
helping the health care workers that are
sacrificing everyday to help those that
are sick on a side note my sister's a
nurse in Detroit and my niece is a nurse
in the Bronx so from conversations with
them I am very aware of the sacrifices
they're making while doing these
literature reviews I have been sadly
disappointed in the poor level of
science that is being exhibited in most
of these articles I know this pandemic
is new and evolving very quickly and
there's a need to get literature out
quickly but I have found that most
articles are either simply opinion
pieces or straight propaganda from
Chinese scientists proclaiming how well
their country handled the situation
having done science for close to 20
years I would normally shrug this off as
papers that were submitted to low
quality journals however I've noticed
that even high quality journals such as
the New England Journal of Medicine and
nature have published papers that are
low in quality and scientific value I am
saddened that the scientific community
seems to be divulging into propaganda
maybe I am naive and believing this is
only happening now as scientists we
often live in a bubble of our specific
field and a certain set of journals
anyway long story short I'm grateful
that you're using the platform to inform
others to be more skeptical of the
literature that is being presented to us
well Chad I appreciate that time insight
that's that's interesting hear from
someone with actual scientific expertise
of which I have none myself all right
why I'm wrong this is from Tony says hey
Matt thanks for a great show you always
have interesting unique perspectives I
was listening to your recent all-access
live show and was a which you can hear
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific
every single day all access live and
this is open to if your daily wire
remember you don't have to be an
all-access member for now and we do
these every day nice little little bit
of companionship a way of breaking up
the isolation
so I did one on Monday and one of the
questions I was asked it's just kind of
back and forth queuing any type of thing
but one of the questions I was asked by
somebody was what do I think are is the
best argument for God for the existence
of God and I gave what I thought was the
best and and what I thought were and I
gave a few examples of arguments that I
thought were not very persuasive and and
I said I think the cosmological argument
the are the argument from first cause
you know any version of that I find
those to be unpersuasive arguments
whereas the argument from consciousness
in my opinion is one of the best
arguments for God okay you said the
cosmological argument was not a strong
argument when in fact it is generally
cited as one of the strongest if not the
strongest argument for God's existence
by many Christian apologists
in response to your objections saying
that the universe can be eternal I think
you missed the point that the universe
is in itself a physical quantity the
universe is composed of time space and
matter which points to a timeless
spaceless and immaterial cause of the
universe furthermore if the universe
somehow extended into the past forever
we would never have arrived at this
current moment the idea of the eternal
universe therefore becomes nonsensical
and finally all current scientific
evidence points to a beginning of the
universe ie the Big Bang Theory not to
criticize you too much but your argument
from consciousness didn't quite square
with me either
could you not say that we evolved to
have a consciousness to help us survive
I've read some things about how
consciousness helps us run simulations
in our head which ultimately help us to
make better decisions looking at this at
it this way couldn't an atheist easily
say we evolved consciousness because it
is beneficial to our species of course
this would be to commit the genetic
fallacy but that's another story thanks
Tony
ok tell me well I would say yeah I know
that I'm taking the contrarian view here
which which probably shouldn't surprise
you and I'm playing devil's advocate ok
so we're talking about what a way what I
think is just from my perspective you
know what are the best arguments for God
and I know that there are some
Christians and many Christians probably
who you talk to who would who would
basically say that every argument for
the existence of God is great and
persuasive and compelling and decisive
but that's just that's obviously our
bias talking
because some arguments are better than
others and you say that the Christian
apologists all say that this is a really
compelling argument well okay but of
course they're gonna find it compelling
say but when you're making an argument
apologetic argument you're not trying to
convince Christian apologists because
they already share your assumptions
there are certain basic assumptions we
bring to the obviously we have a certain
worldview we bring it to every
discussion and so if a certain argument
is compelling to people who share your
basic assumptions that doesn't
necessarily mean it's gonna be
compelling to people who don't share
that assumption and so I think it's
interesting if you can get an atheist
ooh thud filler' theist who's gonna be
honest about it and ask them what do
they think the strongest theistic
arguments are and I've heard you know
many atheists give their opinion on this
and you're not gonna hear them say the
cosmological argument what they will say
oftentimes is a fine-tuning argument
that was in fact Christopher Hitchens
said that he thinks that's the strongest
argument for theism which that doesn't
mean that it's necessarily the best
arguments because Christopher Hitchens
said it but if someone who does not
share your underlying assumptions even
they say okay that's a pretty strong
argument then that should tell you
something so there's that in general
though with the cosmological argument I
think okay here's here's the basic
problem I have with it when you when you
argue that well the universe had to have
a beginning because it's just it's
illogical
right for something to have no beginning
to for it to exist forever so it had to
have some sort of cause and and then god
is that cause well it's it seems like
what you're trying to do is to say that
it is illogical is it's a logical
impossibility for something to have no
cause or no beginning but if it is a
logical impossibility then that would
also apply to God right because even God
cannot do things that are logically
impossible God cannot make a rectangular
Square right or a circular triangle it's
a logical impossibility it's nonsensical
so the whole thing about can God make a
too heavy for him to lift you know
that's it's a it's a logical
impossibility and so sort of the answer
is no and that's there's no real problem
there saying no so it's it seems like
the arguments trying to make a logical
case but then that would apply to God so
what if you say well you know something
has to have a beginning or you know some
something has to have a beginning and
then that's when God is the beginning of
the universe then of course the Atheist
response is well then who started God or
who caused God and typically this is
where most theists will kind of scoff at
that response that's like that's silly
it's actually not a silly response it's
a it's a totally legitimate logical
response to your argument because you
just said that everything has to have a
beginning well God is something isn't he
so it it seems like it's trying to make
a logical argument that it then abandons
when it comes to God and that and that
doesn't quite work also look you know
you
there are ways a theists have ways
around this well they'll say yeah well
we know that there was a big bang we
know that the observable universe has a
beginning but we don't know what
happened before then and we also don't
know you know we could live in a
multiverse we could live in a bubble
universe where there are there trillions
and maybe infinite number of universes
and we're just living in one little one
little section one little bubble that
started 14 billion years ago that
doesn't mean that the entire thing
started 14 billion years ago maybe you
know and maybe every black hole contains
its own universe all kinds of maybes and
what-ifs and that all that sounds
implausible it sounds implausible to me
too but it's not impossible logically it
could be true and I think all the
Atheist needs to do is is say is argue
that it's at least possible that we live
in an eternal multiverse that's it's a
possible thing it's not scientifically
impossible and if you agree to that
which I think you have to because it is
scientifically possible then it kind of
destroys that argument I think but going
to the argument for consciousness now as
I said I think that that is the strong
at least one of the
August arguments for theism along with
the fine-tuning argument I think is
strong and there are others too
the argument for morality I think is
strong but the consciousness argument
now you say the atheist response to that
is is well you know we would have
evolved consciousness because it's very
useful well yeah I could see how
consciousness is useful but this is not
a question of why is consciousness
useful it's how could inanimate matter
first become animate become life and
then develop somehow a sense of its own
self because on a purely materialistic
basis we are all just atoms right we're
all just collections of atoms so how
could it be that a collection of atoms
could come together in a certain way to
develop a stay in experience in
awareness of its own self that to me
seems like it is impossible even almost
a logical impossibility and so it
demands some other kind of immaterial
explanation
especially when consciousness itself
appears to be an immaterial thing and so
that I would argue gets us away from or
it pokes a huge hole in at least
materialism and now you've opened the
door for God and that that's why I think
that's a compelling argument but again
you know I'm speaking as someone who
obviously with a huge bias so that's
just from my my own perspective but
thanks for that email thanks for
everybody for watching have a great day
god bless Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 our exalted experts want to
hold us prisoner to coronavirus for
another 18 months while prosecutors dish
out felony charges to formerly free
Americans who have the goal to go
outside for a walk we will examine the
junk science behind the most outrageous
political power grab of our lifetime
then China infiltrates a White House
press briefing President Trump threatens
to cut funding to the World Health
Organization and Joe Biden steps up and
addresses the nation about his weakness
for fig newtons all that more check it
out on the Michael Noel's show
[Music]